tipping to hole staying at home theme I
wanted to explore a little bit of a
different Avenue today we're going to be
looking at the philips hue smart
lighting system and how it can
revolutionize your home what's going on
guys my name is David Tommy and welcome
back to the channel today like I said
we're looking at the philips hue
lighting system and everything that it
can do and everything that it can't do
everything that comes in the box and
everything that i wish came in the box
so let's start by looking at what
philips hue actually is so if you've
never used or heard of a philips new
system i'm gonna pop this box back down
basically a philips hue system is a
smart lighting system that integrates
with your regular dumb lighting and
wiring usually you'd have to go out and
rewire your whole house see bus cables
running everywhere just to get some sort
of home connectivity and Google
assistance or Amazon Alexa integration
working with your lighting now Philips
has come out with the hue range a couple
years ago and continuously increased
more and more products to make it the
most desirable home lighting solution on
the market in 2020 so basically when you
purchase a Philips hue light you can
plug it into your existing socket and it
is automatically a dimmable smart light
so the total Philips offers 53 different
products that you can purchase right now
in June 2020 from them to accessorize
your house you can have LED lighting
directly behind the computer you can
have LED globes you can have down lights
you could have pendants you can have
exterior and interior lighting water
lights feature lights mirror lights
motion sensors motion detectors and even
smart plugs so the combination of all
these unique lighting objects and
elements you can really do absolutely
anything you want from a standalone
point of view there's three key
differences in the human lighting range
for example the kit by purchase that I'm
going to be displaying today is the
Philips hue white ambient mode so that
allows you to basically use the spectrum
of light
white and yellow it limits you to a cool
white through a warm white whereas you
can also buy just white which is just
your standard warm white color and you
can also jump up to the premium cue
model which is the hue color ambulant
which gives you basically the full RGB
spectrum of colors and you can go to
town or whatever color and whatever
feature you want to make so let's start
with the unboxing experience which is
always the fun part I purchased the
white hue ambulant model as well as an
additional bayonet head globe so in the
box as it comes by default you get a
Philips hue bridge which I'll talk to
you about if you need one or not you get
two Philips hue twist on bulbs and you
get a dimmer switch which originally I
thought I wouldn't need but I can
guarantee you if you're buying a bridge
you 100% need this item and because in
my situation there's two different globe
types in my house I need an additional
Bay and a head so for me I wanted one in
my master bedroom the ensuite and the
office which is here being recorded
today so if I wanted to I could say it
will turn on office light and slowly
it'll come on now I can also use the
command will turn off office light and
it'll turn off so I'm hoping that that
provided enough for light difference in
this video for you guys to actually
notice that light coming on and off
without the switch you have to use
Google all the time or use your phone to
turn it off and on so the switch
actually just makes it a little bit more
convenient especially if you have more
than one globe in the house so why don't
I decide in 2020 that it was the right
time to purchase a Philips hue system
well for me I really like the routine
setup in the Philips you app it gave you
the ability to synchronize these Globes
to adjust to turn on turn off to any
color any time of day that you set up so
for example tomorrow morning being a
Monday as I record
my videos in a Sunday to make sure I
never miss a Monday it will be coming on
at about 5:15 in the morning and slowly
getting brighter and brighter and
brighter until my alarm goes off at 5:30
in the morning this is going to emulate
a sunrise which will hopefully make me
feel a little bit more awake right now
it is the middle of winter at a very
cold dark part of Australia so 5:30 is
pitch black having to get up in a cold
dark room is very unmotivated so for me
I'm using these routines to help me
actually start my day and push forward
as quickly as I can you also have the
ability to integrate philips hue with
your smart assistant so like i
demonstrated previously it can be
integrated with google home amazon alexa
or even the Apple home pots these apps
work independently and together at the
same time you can set the routines to
turn on these lights whenever you want
either inside the Philips hue app or
inside the Google home app depending how
you want to use it you can also then
piggyback certain situations to really
create that home automation lifestyle so
let me give you an example when I go and
have a shower I say
don't enter to do that now so I usually
say X Google shower time and it will one
turn on my bathroom lights to the right
color and to the right dimness that I
personally enjoy and I'll also turn the
right ambient music on that I like so
this is a very bougie thing and nothing
that needs to be done in everybody's
life but it is something that I like
because I'm a tech fanatic hence the
tech channel so this is a really cool
feature that you can integrate into your
life you can then transition out of the
shower I tell it it's type of breakfast
remove your music from one room to
another room change your lighting adjust
it to see exactly what your lifestyle
suits so for example you have a very
long dark hallway and you want each
individual light to come on five seconds
after the other as you walk through that
hallway like a cathedral style or with
motion sensors attached to the bottom
you can absolutely do this with the
Philips hue lighting system the Philips
hue lights really bring in that high-end
automated life style into a very basic
home without needing to spend hundreds
of thousands of dollars on Seabus wiring
just a little pro tip that I found out
whilst using and setting up the routines
in the Philips hue system when you set
up the Philips hue system wake up or a
sunrise sunset activation sensors in the
app and tell it to turn on at a specific
time for example like I mentioned at
5:15 tomorrow morning when you select
5:15 that is when you want it to be as
bright as possible at its maximum
setting so it will start at 4:45 and
slowly turn on to 5:15 or if you want it
to start at 5:15 it will slowly turn on
to 5:45 you can also set this to 10 20
and 30 minute intervals so it really
depends how quickly you want to wake up
but this is important to note because I
was testing it for a very very long time
going well it's 25 in the morning and
it's not turning on or it's 3:30 in the
afternoon and it's not turning on
why they're not turning on but that's
because I always setting it to a minute
in the future hoping it would start and
turn on already
whereas what I needed to do was set it
11 minutes into the future or 31 minutes
into the future depending on the setting
I'd set to actually turn on 30 minutes
prior so this isn't something that's
really explained in the hue app and it's
definitely something to watch out for
because for a long time I sat there
thinking you're not broken something or
any if you like your lighting to be a
bit more colorful a bit more playful a
bit more entertaining you can actually
purchase the color ambulant models of
the lighting I purchased and have it
sync with your entertainment or with
your gaming so what that does for
example is it syncs your Philips you
system on your phone to the Philips you
system on your MacBook or your PC and as
you're playing a movie or playing video
games on your computer it automatically
recognizes the sounds and the colors and
adjusts accordingly so this is something
that really can get you into a more of a
gaming mood or really enhance your home
cinema if this is something that you're
looking for growing up in one of the
rough and neighborhoods of Australia
you're always taught to leave the lights
on when you left home or leave some
light on so some it looks like
somebody's home the one thing that
Philips you adds is security to your
home lifestyle so if you're leaving home
and you're going on a holiday for two
weeks for example and nobody's going to
be home but you want to make sure the
lights are on spontaneously at different
times in different rooms this is
something the Philips use system can
again automate for you you can customize
that the bedroom lights again turn on at
5:30 like they usually do the front
porch light turns on at 5:30 at night
when you're meant to come home and all
sorts of different combinations to make
it appear as if somebody is still living
inside the house so it isn't exactly a
high-tech security feature but it is a
deterrent for some people and something
that warrants some people buying the
Philips hue system in my opinion this
was a bit of a tack on from Philips
because of the location-aware
software inside the hue app so when you
start leaving work it picks up your
location if you turn on that you're
coming home for
work and as you enter the door it
automatically turns on all your lights
so therefore you're greeted to your home
as if somebody's was already there this
is a pretty cool feature but because I
only have this in my bedroom and my
office it isn't really that useful for
me if I walk through the door there's a
little bit of a step through that
bedroom so it's still pitch-black most
of the time however if you do have a
philips Lighting setup throughout your
whole house you can very easily program
that to turn on your living spaces as
you're walking through the door and
genuinely greet you as you come home now
the philips hue app is also testing a
whole bunch of labs products as they
like to call them these are almost ready
but not a hundred percent ready software
integrations that you can integrate into
your daily routine so for example if you
have a color ambulant light you can do a
quick workout or you can do a guided
yoga session with a standard white hue
ambient light you can do a guided
meditation session so none of these are
perfect they aren't all voice-guided
some are some aren't you can either in
set candle light romantic settings with
the light so they flicker on and off in
a nice orange Pantone color or you can
even go one step further with the color
ambulant lights and shift from light
shades of pink to green to blue whatever
this system sets so there are a million
one different functionalities and
add-ons there's some even third-party
applications that you can wrap your
strip LED lights around your Christmas
tree and it will do all sorts of
different lighting effects which is
really cool come Christmas time so there
is an endless endless amount of things
that you can do with the color software
integration into these lights so what's
my overall verdict on these lights how
simple is it to set up what can we
really do and what can we expect them to
do well I honestly spent about 3-4 hours
yesterday just playing around with it
understanding how the routines work
integrating it into my Google
and getting those routine set up so when
I woke up this morning the lights turned
on the music played it was all really
nice and a bit more luxurious I guess
the skills required to set this thing up
a very basic you take the old light
globe out you plug the new light globe
in and you go from there
if you're planning on using routines
then you're 100% where we need the
bridge the bridge is a little square
modem that sits plugged directly into
your modem and lets all the lights
communicate through Wi-Fi if you're only
planning on using your phone to turn
them off and on and change the color of
them then you absolutely do not need a
bridge and you can go out and purchase
one of the cheapest shipping light bulbs
which I think range from about thirty to
forty Australian dollars all the way up
to about ninety for the colored versions
overall I think they're a great little
addition to making your life a little
bit different a little bit more quirky
and a little bit more luxurious I really
truly do hope that one day I can fully
automate my home into iron man's the
whole premises where everything is done
based on your home assistant anyway
thanks for watching guys I hope you
enjoyed the video if you did make sure
you smash that subscribe button
20:20 style and as always I'll see you
next Monday